[Música]
la oposición turca presentó su candidato
a las elecciones presidenciales de mayo
para competir contra erdogan justo
cuando se cumple hoy un mes de los
terremotos que devastaron Siria y
Turquía en los que murieron más de
52.000 personas una catástrofe que puede
marcar el futuro político del actual
presidente
en el frente oriental de la guerra en
Ucrania los combates avanzan en badmud
el jefe del grupo Wagner que había
asegurado tener la ciudad prácticamente
cercada volvió a reclamar a Moscú por la
falta de municiones aseguró que si
Wagner se retira de bacmut todo el
frente caerá
el jefe de acné al qaeda en el magreb
habló en exclusiva con France 24 el
grupo fundamentalista confirmó tener
secuestrado al periodista francés Olivia
Eduard y abre la puerta las
negociaciones con el gobierno de París
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masdeo y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abramos esta edición
informativa en Turquía porque la
coalición de oposición turca declaró a
que malcdaroglu como su candidato para
enfrentarse a erdogan en las elecciones
presidenciales del mes de mayo nuestro
corresponsal en Estambul adrià Rocha no
se amplía sobre el perfil del candidato
después de un fin de semana de luchas
fraticidas entre la oposición turca hoy
mismo hace unos minutos la oposición que
se enfrentará al presidente Turco
recepta y erdogan en las elecciones del
14 de mayo haya aclarado quién será su
candidato para esas elecciones se trata
de que el presidente del principal
partido de la oposición al partido
republicano del pueblo un burócrata de
74 años no muy carismático Pero quien se
cree que puede ser el que abarque la
gran diversidad que hay dentro de la
oposición turca que abarca desde el
nacionalismo de la derecha turca hasta
partidos incluso comunistas y el partido
procurdo del gdp el tercero en
representación parlamentaria estos dos
partidos el comunista y el gdp el
partido por kurdon no están dentro de la
coalición opositora pero sí que aseguran
y lo han hecho Durante los últimos meses
que apoyarán a cualquier candidato que
se enfrente en contra del presidente
Turco está ahí Perdón que ve como las
elecciones que se aproximan será unas
elecciones clave no solo por el
terremoto que ocurrió hace hoy mismo
hace justo un mes que ha bajado la
Popular del presidente que ya estaba muy
baja de por sí Después de varios años de
una crisis inflacionaria tremenda en
Turquía la inflación ahora mismo se
encuentra en torno a 55% oficial números
extraoficiales la situan mucho más alta
y es algo que se nota los turcos lo
notan en cada día que pasa
como nos decía adrià desde Estambul la
gestión del terremoto es una de las
cuestiones que puede marcar la suerte
política de erdogan en las
presidenciales de mayo hoy precisamente
se cumple un mes de la catástrofe que
devastó parte de Turquía y también de
Siria y en la que murieron más de 52.000
personas a esta hora prosiguen los
trabajos de limpieza de escombros
mientras todavía hay cientos de
desaparecidos por el momento además
cerca de 200 personas han sido
procesadas ante la justicia por su
responsabilidad en la precaria
construcción de los edificios afectados
en noticias de la guerra en Ucrania el
grupo de mercenarios Wagner denuncia que
Moscú no provee a sus combatientes la
munición suficiente para ganar la
batalla de bakmuth comentarios que
apuntan a una posible ruptura entre el
ejército del kremlin y este grupo
paramilitar privado que ha sido un actor
clave en la ofensiva rusa recordemos que
desde hace días el grupo Wagner asegura
que tiene la ciudad de bacmut
prácticamente cercada sin embargo de
momento las fuerzas ucranianas se
resisten a La retirada
según todas las apariencias es el hombre
que encabeza el asalto de Rusia a la
ciudad de ucraniana de batmut
dirige al grupo paramilitar periodo
Wagner y en los últimos días ha dicho
que sus tropas tenían prácticamente
rodeada la ciudad pero que estaban
siendo privadas de munición prigó sin
cuestionó si el retraso en el suministro
de municiones era solo burocracia
ordinaria o una traición del kremlin y
dijo que a su representante se le había
negado el acceso al cuartar general
militar de Rusia
en un vídeo publicado el viernes aseguró
que no podía ver más en juego
si Wagner se retira de bacmut ahora todo
el frente se derrumbará hoy Wagner es el
pegamento que mantiene todo Unido
abrigo sin parece preocuparle que Moscú
quiera utilizar a Wagner como posible
Chivo expiatorios y Rusia sufre una
derrota en el campo de batalla y no es
la primera vez que arremete contra el
kremlin el mes pasado acusó al ministro
de defensa ruso sergi de traición por
retener municiones por su parte
Moscú afirma que es absolutamente falso
que se esté privando a Wagner de
munición y el Ministerio de defensa
anunció el lunes que el propio había
visitado la ciudad de maripol devastada
por la guerra un año después de que las
fuerzas rusas la arrasaran
mientras prego sin intensifica sus
críticas al kremlin en el último mes han
surgido indicios de que Moscú quiere
cortarle las alas pero en Ucrania Wagner
está desempeñando un papel clave en la
invasión rusa tiene decenas de miles de
soldados sobre el terreno algunos
reclutados directamente de las cárceles
rusas en otras noticias la justicia de
velarus ha sentenciado en ausencia a la
líder opositora es Bed lana tillano
uscaya a 15 años de prisión condenada
por cargos de traición esto según
informó la agencia Estatal de noticias
Delta este lunes la opositora huyó de
velarus después de presentarse a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2020 contra
el actual presidente Alexander
lukashenko un gran Aliado de Putin y que
está en el poder desde
1994 a los comicios de 2020 recordemos
les siguió una ola de protestas masivas
que acusaban a lucashenko de fraude
electoral
ya tildado el proceso judicial contra
ella de farsa
en Pakistán la organización de la
autoproclamado estado islámico
reivindicó el ataque bomba que mató a
nueve personas e hirió a otras siete
este lunes en el suroeste del país según
confirmó site intelligence Group una
página que rastrea las actividades de
grupos extremistas islamistas en este
caso se trató de un atentado suicida
contra un vehículo de policía el más
reciente episodio de una serie de
ataques contra la fuerza pública
pakistaní esta tarde las autoridades
locales visitaron a los supervivientes
en el hospital
y se repiten los envenenamientos de
niñas en Irán las menores hospitalizadas
por inhalar gases tóxicos en las
escuelas se cuentan por decenas mientras
el origen de los ataques que empezaron
en noviembre continúa sin esclarecerse
este lunes el líder supremo de Irán el
ayatolá aliye pidió castigar severamente
a los responsables que vínculo con un
supuesto complot de los enemigos de la
República islámica otras autoridades
iraníes atribuyeron los casos a la
ansiedad colectiva sin embargo otras
voces políticas se enteran apuntan a
grupos fundamentalistas que se oponen a
la educación de las niñas la Casa Blanca
también se pronunció al respecto y
aseguró que sería vergonzoso que se
impida el acceso de menores a la
educación leurel tiene los detalles
día tras día el fenómeno se repite
alumnas de escuelas femeninas en Irán
inhalan olores descritos como
desagradables o desconocidos y luego
presentan síntomas como náuseas disnea o
mareos en su primera reacción pública de
la yatora alija meney condenó firmemente
estos actos negaron los perpetradores
deben ser condenados a un Severo castigo
ese es un crimen grave e imperdonable no
habrá amnistía para ellos Sonia
desde noviembre las autoridades han
registrado presuntos ataques en más de
50 escuelas de 25 de las 31 provincias
iraníes y según un recuento oficial ya
sería unas mil las colegiadas afectadas
los incidentes han desencadenado una ola
de indignación y de temor en todo el
país así como reiteradas exigencias al
ejecutivo para que tome medidas
concretas
no debería permitirse que este tipo de
cosas ocurran a los niños en estos
tiempos
pido al gobierno que actúe con rapidez
para proteger las vidas de la próxima
generación todas las madres de Irán
están angustiadas por los
envenenamientos
el viceministro de sanidad dijo que los
presuntos ataques tenían como objetivo
interrumpir la educación de las niñas
actividad achacada grupos extremistas
algunas alumnas son hospitalizadas
brevemente Pero según las autoridades
ninguna ha resultado gravemente afectada
hasta el momento mientras la
investigación para determinar de qué
substancia se trata continúa la policía
iraní aumentó este lunes la presencia de
patrullas en los centros educativos
femeninos lo que no ha evitado nuevos
casos de intoxicaciones
vamos ahora con la noticia exclusiva que
avanzamos en los titulares el jefe de
admin las siglas de al qaeda en el
magreb islámico abueida Joseph alanabí
respondió a una serie de preguntas al
periodista oasing nacer de France 24
casi dos años después
de la captura del periodista francés
Olivier dubá en Mali el grupo
fundamentalista confirma tener los
secuestrado y abre la puerta a las
negociaciones al qaeda asegura que la
pelota está en el campo del gobierno de
macron previamente analizamos el caso
con Luis Alberto villamarín investigador
especialista en al qaeda
pues es un duro golpe para macron que
está empeñando toda su agenda exterior
en Ucrania y con lo que ya le hemos
visto en los medios pero es un reto
grande para Europa Porque si usted Mira
el mapa
al frente de la Costa Sur de Europa
usando el Mediterráneo está la costa
norte de África que es como la
retaguardia estratégica de lo que quiso
sama Bin Laden de colocarlo allí
entonces lo más seguro es que con este
periodista van a buscar una serie de
manipulaciones buscando concesiones y
buscando presiones para Europa pero lo
más grave Rosa que mientras tanto pueden
retornar a algo que se ha tranquilizado
un poco en Europa que son las acciones
yihadistas en cualquiera de los países
europeos y naturalmente en este caso
Francia está en la mira por haber
participado en malí por los combates que
hay y por la intención que tiene al
qaeda de controlar no solamente el
magreb islámico sino bajar el centro de
África y alzagel vamos con información
de nuestra región en Nicaragua el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega cesó las
operaciones de todas las cámaras
empresariales del país mediante la
cancelación de la personalidad jurídica
del Consejo superior de la empresa
privada así como de las entidades que lo
integraban la resolución fue publicada
en el diario oficial la gaceta y se basa
en que las organizaciones no cumplieron
el proceso de registro de acuerdo a la
Ley Sin embargo el periódico
independiente la prensa que opera desde
el exilio informa que las empresas
enfrentaron varios obstáculos para
tramitar dichos procedimientos además
los principales dirigentes del Consejo
de la empresa privada forman parte de
los 200 desterrados a Estados Unidos
este mes de febrero
y en México más de 100 menores no
acompañados fueron encontrados dentro de
un camión abandonado en el estado de
Veracruz se trata de uno de los mayores
hallazgos de niños que viajan sin
compañía Por México en un intento por
llegar a la frontera estadounidense
además de los 103 menores viajaban
también en dicho vehículo 212 adultos
principalmente de Guatemala Honduras El
Salvador y Ecuador los menores se serán
puestos a disposición de las autoridades
competentes de Veracruz mientras que los
adultos serán procesados hasta
determinar su estatus legal
en otras noticias la empresa que fabrica
el chocolate toblerone retira de sus
envases la icónica imagen del pico
matterhore También conocido como Monte
servino al trasladar parte de su
producción a Europa del este el
chocolate ya no puede considerarse
legalmente hecho en Suiza la marca
anunció que Próximamente presentará su
nuevo empaque con otra tipografía y
elementos distintivos
durante más de un siglo esta tableta de
chocolate en forma de triángulo ha sido
definida por su tradición Suiza
pero cuando se trata de reivindicar lo
hecho en Suiza parece que no hay
territorio neutral la empresa matriz
estadounidense de toblerone está
trasladando parte de su producción a
Eslovaquia lo que significa que el
chocolate ya no cumple la definición
legal para considerarse suizo la marca
pronto eliminará cualquier referencia
que está hecha en Suiza y perderá la
icónica imagen del pico de la montaña
materhoon sustituyéndola por algo más
genérico la empresa lo anunció
relanzaremos el envase de toblerone a
partir de este verano diciendo que la
marca fue establecida en Suiza en 2017
los legisladores suizos aprobaron una
ley que prohíbe que los símbolos
nacionales aparezcan en productos que no
cumplan Los criterios de suizo la ley
exige que cualquier artículo alimenticio
que se comercialice como hecho en Suiza
obtenga el 80% de sus materias primas
del país esto aumenta al 100% para los
productos lácteos ha habido polémicas
similares en torno al queso suizo el
viernes pasado un tribunal de Estados
Unidos dictaminó que el queso no tenía
que producirse cerca de la frontera
Franco Suiza para llamarse gruyer el más
reciente desarrollo en una larga lucha
legal internacional
en cuanto a tolerone el nuevo envase se
presentará este verano y la empresa
afirma que incluirá un nuevo tipo de
letra y logotipo distintivos y la firma
de su fundador suizo que creó la tableta
de chocolate en 1908
y nos despedimos con imágenes de la
Aurora boreal en laponia Finlandia este
domingo sobre tepasto a 200 km del
Círculo Polar Ártico el cielo apareció
teñido de colores un fenómeno que en los
pasados días también protagonizó las
largas noches invernales del propio
Círculo Polar según fotógrafos locales
2023 está siendo un año espectacular
para observar estas olas de luz
con estas imágenes Nos despedimos pero
sigan con nosotros y más información
[Música]